Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No playing Hot Potato
with SCP-963!
SCP-963 is the ornate, anomalous amulet that
contains Dr. Jack Bright's consciousness.
Any living subject that comes into contact
with this amulet ceases brain function, and
their consciousness is replaced with Dr. Bright's.
If they remain in contact with the amulet
for longer than 30 days, they will retain
this consciousness even after the amulet has
been removed.
Otherwise, they will experience brain death.
Essentially, it should be taken incredibly
seriously, and handled with great care.
It should not be tossed at a random D-Class,
Research Assistant, or any other Foundation
staff member with shouts of "CATCH!"
or used to play any other high-stakes contact-based
game.
It is not, in fact, a "fun team-building exercise,"
that should be played on company retreats.